abone ol
eve gidiyorum
Herkese merhabalar ben size bu Yorucu
günün sonunda ülkemizin en uzak
köşelerinden bir tanesinden hep Üzücü
haberler aldığınız yerden Van gölünden
Umuda geçen bir balığın hikayesini
anlatmak için buradayım İnci kafalı
Dünyada sadece Van Gölü'nde yaşayan
endemik bir balık türü yaşamını Van
Gölü'nün tuzu sodalı sularında geçiriyor
Ama gölün suları üremesine Uygun
olmadığı için İlkbahar aylarında büyük
Sürüler halinde akarsulara göç ediyor bu
öyle bir göç ki gelincikler açtığında
Mayıs sonu haziran başı gibi Van
Gölü'nün çevresindeki tüm Dereler
akıntının tersine giden balıklarla
doluyor bu balık köşe başladığı anda
bu beslenmiyor yem almıyor ve göçü
tamamlanıncaya kadar inanılmaz
zahmetlere Katlanıyor önüne çıkan
engelleri Şelaleleri atlayarak
zıplayarak bazen uçarak geçmeye
çalışıyor ve bu esnada önüne çıkan doğal
ve doğal olmayan bir sürü düşmanıyla
mücadele ediyor işte benim hayatımda
balığın hayatının karıştığı yerde Tam
burada başlıyor Ben 1992 yılında
saçlarım varken genç bir asistan olarak
gittiğim Van Gölü kenarına Van Yüzüncü
Yıl Üniversitesi'ne ve inci kefali ile
ilgili çalışmaya başladım bir doktora
tezi hazırladım doktora tezimi
hazırladığımız zaman şöyle bir manzara
vardı Van'da inci kefali ile ilgili
olarak valiliğin karşısında üreme
zamanında her sabah 20 kamyon dolusu
bu kafalı satılıyordu ve İnci kefalinin
yumurtaları kamyonun kasasının
kenarlarından yollara akıyor kırmızı
kırmızı utanç izler bırakıyordu tuzunu
neredeyse bir şehir komple balık
kokuyordu ve bu esnada Bu esnada aslında
herkes balık korunuyor gibi yapıyor ama
aslında balık korunuyordu işte doktora
tezim esnasında ben bu balıkla ilgili
çalışmalar yaptım stok tespitini yaptım
ve alternatif bir Balıkçılık yönetim
modeli geliştirdim alternatif Balıkçılık
yönetim modelinde yaptığım şey şuydu
inci kefal ın Sürdürülebilir balıkçılığı
ulaşması için birtakım tedbirler
öneriler söz konusuydu ve ilk iş olarak
tarım Bakanlığı'na gittim ilgili Şube
müdürüne heyecanlı anlattım genç bir
asistanım heyecan kulaklarımdan
fışkırıyor anlatıyorum ama beni dinleyen
Bu ürün kafamı kaldırdığımda
sayıkladığını Gördüm hatta saklamakla
kalmayıp bana ya Hoca kaç ton tespit
ettin gölde balık diye sordu Ben de 43
bin ton dedim iyi Bana yaklaş mısın dedi
Nasıl olur siz de biz çok tahmini
yaptığınız dedim Çünkü sok tahmini zor
bir iş ben üç yılda yaptığım 27.000
balık ölçtüm tüm neredeyse Bu üç yılın
her günü arazide oldum yok dedi Biz
arkadaşlarla Çay içiyorduk şöyle bir
baktık bahse girdik Ben de 50 bin ton
demiştim dedi Yani benim o kadar
uğraşmama gerek yokmuş Müdür ben şöyle
yapmış ve her şeyi görmüş Tabii bi
ve savcılık değil yetersiz avcılık var
Avcılar artırmak lazım dedi Dükkana
gittim Vallahi ben anlamam de direktöre
gittim Vallahi benim işim değil dedi
valiye gittim vali beni ilgiyle dinledi
Dinledi Sonra dedi ki ya hoca Burası
terör bölgesi Ben insanların güvenliğini
sağlamakla mükellefi Ben şimdi
insanların camlarının emniyetini
sağlamak Tan kaygı duyarken Sen bir böl
dolusu balık çıkarıyorsun başıma deli
misin kardeşim git başımdan dedi Neyse
Sonuçta bari ikna ettim de herkesin
katıldığı bir toplantıyla inci kafalının
Sürdürülebilir Balıkçı içi balıkçılığı
için yapılması gerekenleri açıkladı ama
toplantıda Benim anlattıklarım
tartışılması adı Toplantıda ne
tartışıldığı toplantıda Vali ile bir
Kaçak balıkçının tartışması ve kavga
etmeleri olay oldu bu kavgadan insanlar
korktu bir anda 200 tane
o kızgın insanda Baş Başa Kaldım tüm
devlet ricali kayboldu yok oldular bir
anda da o çok şükür o gün postu
deldirmeden paçayı kurtardık ve bir
karar verdim Dedim ki bundan sonra yani
bu balığın bu acınacak halde ki balığın
geleceği için eğer Ben bir şey yaparsam
yapacağım başka kimseden fayda yok
küstüm devlete Evet küstüm yok dedim
Benim için devlet yok madem bilime Değer
vermiyorlar ben de gideceğim bu Kaçak
balıkçılarla anlatacağım da bu işi
çözeceğim dedim gitti çözmeye Kaçak
balıkçılarla altı ay süren bir anlaşma
sürecimiz git geçti Tiya hu Yapmayın
etmeyin olmuyor tabi ki bu iş ve en
sonunda şu gör
O benim el Yazım da yazdığımız bir
anlaşma imzaladık yani İki yıllığına av
yasaklarını Tarım Bakanlığı tamamen
kaldırılmasını talep ediyor balıkçılar
iki yıl biz bol bol balık avlayalım
balık satıcıları da yüksek fiyattan
balığımızı satın alsınlar bizde iki
yılın sonunda kafamıza göre herkes
kendine bir iş yapsın Biri Mermerci
Olsun birisi her acı olsun Biri inek
yetişirsin vesaire Bu gayet mantıklı
Peki nasıl uygulayacağız her şeyi yazdık
hesap ettik kitap ettik fakat bir sorun
var balıkçılar diyorlar ki devlet zaten
uygulamıyor bu av yasağı bizi kötü
vatandaş durumunda düşürme Hoca git
devlette konuş İki yıllığına ve
yasaklarını kaldırsın sürekli tarım
Bakanlığı'na av yasaklarını kaldırır
diye öneren ben bu sefer Tarım
Bakanlığı'nın kapısını ki mavi
yasaklarını kaldırın biz böyle bir
anlaşma yaptık diye çaldım Ne dediler
sizce
Ama siz olsanız ne derdiniz Allah razı
olsun Hoca Sen ne güzel bir şey
yapıyorsun ya harika mı Derdiniz siz
öyle derdiniz Eminim ama Tarım Bakanlığı
beni mahkemeye verdi ki inci kefal
balığının nesli tük ettirmek kek Evet
balıkçılarla çıkar ilişkisine girmek
kvan Yüzyıl Üniversitesi ile Tarım
Bakanlığı'nın arasını bozmak suçuyla
hakimin karşısına çıktık çok çok şükür
orada beraat etti kurtardık Çünkü
yüzümüz ak' yaptığımız yanlış bir şey
yok fakat devlete küsmüştük devletle
kötüydük balıkçılar şimdi oradan karar
çıkmayınca dediler koca bir zaten
şüphelenmiş tik sen bize tamam dedin
bizi ikna ettin Ama gittin devlete dedim
ki sakın kaldırmayın av yasaklarının
dedim
Ama bu sefer balıkçıyla da Aramız
bozuldu kaldı ortaya evde ne yapabilirim
İnci kafalı çaresiz Bu arada Tonlarca
balık avlamaya devam ediyor hala
balıklar atlıyorlar çaresiz bir şekilde
devam ediyorlar Bu sefer beri İşin
başında yalnızım ama daha sonradan bir
sürü insanlar etrafında yavaş yavaş
toplanmaya başladı Sevgili şarkı varsa
Fertan geldi İstanbul'dan bana
katıldılar bir arabam var eski bir araba
dolaşıyorum Van Gölü'nün çevresinde
sürekli ve insanları anlatıyorum Elimde
bir bilgisayar bak Ahmet'e bir bak Ayşe
Teyze diye sürekli anlatıyorum eğitim
setleri var elimde araba bazen
çalışmıyorum itekliyor köylüler yola
devam ediyoruz öylece acıyor lar bana
üzülüyorlar evliyim arkadaşlarımız ev
alıyorlar arabalarını yeniliyorlar
ve her şey değişiyor Yahu hanım soruyor
bana Bizim paralar nerede üzgünüm
paralar Van Gölü'nde inci kefal ama
geliyor yapacak bir şey yok yok ve bu
turların sonunda ne oldu biliyor musunuz
Bir sürü kurum kuruluşunu içinde bir
sürü vicdanlı insanlar var Onlar
harekete geçtiler bir şeyler değişmesi
gerektiğine inandılar ve Bu gördüğünüz
Van Gölü'nün çevresinde ki Ahmet temli
Yusuf dayı Ayşe teyze Ali bana destek
olmaya başladılar ve bu turlar sonuç
vermeye başladı inci kefali nın Kaçak
avcılığı bir nebze de olsun önlenmeye
başladı kamu kurumları harekete geçmeye
başladı Çünkü sürekli inci kefali ile
ilgili haberler çıkıyor sürekli bir
şeyler oluyor bundan birazcık kaygı
duydular bu beni çok mutlu etti ama
Kaçak balıkçıları çok musun
ama onlar baktılar işin ucu kötüye
gidiyor bir taraftan siyasi baskıyı
artırdılar alın bu Mustafa Hoca'yı Biz
bunu burada İstemiyoruz diye sürekli
baskı yapmaya başladılar Bir taraftan da
bana tehdit telefonları arttı gittiğim
yerlerde tehdit ediliyorum evimi
arıyorlar öldüreceğiz çocuğunu
kaçıracağız o günlerde bir de hakimi
çocuğunu kaçırdı bu Kaçak balıkçılar
böyle olunca korktum ve bir yol ayrımına
geldiğini düşündüm çünkü bir karar
verecektim ya devam edecektim ya da pır
akıp başka bir yerde başka bir
mücadeleyle hayatını sürdürecek Team E
şimdi konuşmaya karar verdim Dedim ki
Hanım durum bu ya gideceğiz yol
ayrımındayız bugüne kadar yaptıklarımızı
burada bırakacağız gideceğiz başka bir
şey yapacağız ya da devam edeceğiz Ne
diyorsun Önce kadar seviyor musun önce
kadar istiyor musun bu işidir istiyorum
dedim
O zaman devam et sen ölürsen çocuklara
ben bakarım dedi sağ olsun bu bu
verdiğimiz karar tüm ailemizin hayatını
pozitif yönde etkiledi negatif
etkileyebilir di mi öyle edebilirdik ama
bu Güner burada konuşuyorsak bu
negatifin üstünde durmaya hiç gerek yok
bence ve bu eğitimler esnasında bir
Balıkçı bana bir gün bir şey söyledi
dedi ki Hoca sen gelirsen bize
anlatıyorsun ile ile ile biz dirhe
Vallahi vallahi vallahi sonra Sen
gidiyorsan işine Biz gidiyor işimize
Babam bu iş böyle olmaz Sen beni kendine
yardımcı yapacaksan bana çok da para
vereceksin sonra ben gideceğim derenin
bu elime alacağım bir sopa yeni de
döveceğim gelmeyebilir döneceğiz bak
sorun nasıl çözülür bizim balıkçının
önerisinin yanlış olduğunu tartışmaya
gerek yok fakat Allah ondan razı olsun
ufkumuzu açtı bıçağı Çünkü ben gidiyorum
anlatıyorum diyorum ki bak Ahmet dayı
ekosistem diye bir şey var harç çiçekler
balıklar böcekler Her şey bu ekosistemin
içinde de sen şimdi bu balıkları
ağladığında bu zincir kopuyor Bora Ahmet
dayı dinliyor have Allah diyor
çiçeklerden bahsediyorum have Allah
diyor Sonra ben gidiyorum üniversiteye
onlar Kaçak balığı Alo velo gelinden
gidelim ballı diyorlar ya bu iş böyle
olmaz Anladık ki bizim mekanik ekoloji
anlattığımız işe yaramıyor ve
O bize tanımlanan Bize öğretilen
katılımcılık teorisi En azından Van
Gölü'nün çevresinde çevresel konularda
çalışmıyor yeni bir gün yeni bir
Balıkçılık yönetim modeli geliştirmiş
Lig yeni bir katılımcılık modeli
geliştirdik tamamen özgün bir ekoloji
anlatımı benimsedik ve bu sonuç verdiği
15 Balıkçı köyünün 12 tanesi Kaçak
avcılıktan Vazgeçti güç tane kaldı ama
onlar diyorlar ki eğer bizi öldürdüğü
kurşuna diz bir kişi sağ kalırsak
kalkacak O Balıkçılık yapmaya devam
edecek İş inada bindi Yahu Bildiğim her
şeyi iflas etti bilim iflas etti ben
köylü kökenliyim köylünün davranışlı
bilirim yok Arkadaş çalışmıyor bu sefer
Yolumuz aydınlatmak için Van Gölü
çevresinde sos
Bu klorik araştırma diye bir araştırma
başlattı Güven lifinin desteğiyle
ekibimize Profesör Halil nalçaoğlu dahil
ettik sosyolog olarak sevgili Solmaz
Karabaş ayı dahil ettik halk bilimci
olarak vazgeçenlerden Vazgeçti
vazgeçmeyenler ne de ısrar ediyorlar
bunu bulmak için harekete geçtik ve yy8
köy hedeflemiş tik 24 köyde durabildi
kekik inanılmaz bir sonuç çıktı işte her
şey burada Burada gördüğünüz şu sosyal
kültürel bireysel indeks değerleri
ortaya çıktı ve en önemli ki
bulduğumuzdan bir tanesi neydi Anladık
ki bizim balıkçıları üreme dönemindeki
Kaçak avcılıkla ısrar etmiyorlar her
türlü değişme direniyorlar bir değişime
direnç var bu çok güzel çok memnun edici
insanlarla kavga etmeye gerek yok o
zaman o zaman ben bu insanların değişimi
dirençlerini hafifletecek bir yol
bulursam balı
bu sorular başka şeyler de
yaptırabilirim yapabiliriz beraber Peki
ne yapalım nereden başlayalım Bu esnada
şeyi görmüştük eşine ulaştığımız
hanımlara ulaştığımız Balıkçıların kısa
süre içerisinde Kaçak balıkçılığı terk
ettiğini görmüştük dedik ki hanımlarda
yürüyelim çünkü şu Çünkü bizim
kültürümüzde her ne kadar Barata erkil
bir toplum Sak erkek ha kimse de erkeğin
ne diyeceğine genellikle arkadaşı teyzem
karar verir bir kere söyler ama tekrar
etmez Biz de dedik ki Van Gölü
çevresindeki Balıkçı köylerinde doğru ve
dengeli beslenmede Balık'ın yeri ve
önemine güzel bir başlık değil mi Sow
kimseye değmez dokunmaz ve bu çalışmayla
24 köyde Kadınlara yönelik çalışmalar
yaptık ve sonu
bu tarihi da ne oldu biliyor musunuz
ğniversite yeğen yakın Kaçak Balıkçılık
ısrar eden köye gittiğimizde gözlerimizi
yaşartan şu manzarayla karşılaştık bir
Balıkçı eşi kocası ve Oğulları kaçak
balık avlamaya gidemezsin diye Balıkçı
teknesinin üstüne Bu kez ek yağını
yapmış teyze çok kıymetli geze çok
kıymetli Tanrı'ya tüp ekmek pişirecek
siniz teyze ihtiyacınız var banyo
yapacaksınız size ihtiyacınız var kışın
sobayı yapacaksınız keze ihtiyacınız var
kezek çok önemli ve bu böyle gözlerimizi
yaşartan bir olayla karşılaştık Yani
bizim bu uzun meşakkatli zahmetli inci
kefali yla ilgili mücadelemize son
noktayı kocaman noktayı geri dönülemez
noktayı umut dolu noktayı Anılar koydu
kadınlar koydum
ve onlara hürmet ediyorum Peki nereye
geldik biz şimdi Geldiğimiz Yer bu işte
Kaçak balıkların satıldığı meydanda
Van'da şimdi inci kefali heykeli var
Van'da bu Van Gölü'nün çevresinde inci
kefali Ortaokulu var inci kefali
İlkokulu var bu Van Emniyet Müdürlüğü
Erciş Kaymakamlığı Muradiye
Kaymakamlığı'nın logosunda atlayan incik
yapanlar mı mı İnci kefalinin cirosu 1.2
milyon dolardan 12 milyon dolara çıktı
Ben Devlet memuruyum benim maaşım
aynıdır bu para o bölgedeki insanların
cebine girdi Teşekkür ederim sağ olun
Teşekkür ederim
abone ol
1'inci kafalı yolculuğu işte böyle zorlu
bir yolculuk ve inci kefali bugün ünvan
gölün çevresinde yaşamına devam ediyor
yaşamını sürdürüyor sanki Tevfik Fikret
Şu aşağıdaki mısraları şiiri Van
Gölü'nün kenarında İnci kafalarda
seyrederken yazmış koşan elbet varır
düşenkalkar Karataş'tan su damla damla
akar birikir sonunda bir Gümüş göl olur
arayan Hakkı en sonunda bulur inci kefal
ı aradığını bulduğu için tüm
engellemelere rağmen Asırlardır Derelere
gelmeye devam ediyor vazgeçmediği için
İnci kafalı yaşamaya devam ediyor Ben
aradığımı bulduğum için 23 yıl yaşadım
Van Gölü'nün kenarında bir aile kurdum
iki tane pırlanta gibi evlat yetiştirdim
[Alkış]
sizde
Ama siz aradıklarını buldunuz mu mu ya
bulamadıysanız ya da beğenmediğiniz
hoşlanmadığınız şeyler varsa İşte şu
anda tam zamanı şimdi inci kefali gibi
vazgeçme Umut et diyeceksiniz Çünkü ben
mücadele etmeyi bunları yapmayın cik
yapalım dan öğrendim şu şelaleden geriye
gidiş yok İnci kefalleri asla geri
dönmez o zaman Sıra Sizde Eğer cesaret
toplamak isterseniz bahar aylarında
gelincikler açtığında İnci kafaları Van
Gölü'nün çevresinde hasretle sizi
bekliyor olacak Saygılarımla
Saygılarımla Sağ olun teşekkür ediyorum
Teşekkür ediyorum Sağ olun
abone ol